so that's one of my things whether or
not the audience knows about it I know
about the character's past and I just
want the actors to know now the audience
doesn't need to know like for instance
Brad Pitt's character although all the
rain has a rope burn exactly around his
neck my name is Lieutenant Aldo rain and
I'm putting together a special team but
I never want to explain what happened I
desperately wanted to know well I wanted
to just figure it out all right I mean
that's up to you to to supply where that
rope burn came from I like the idea that
okay if you contemplate why there is a
rope burn there and somebody else
contemplates whether it's a Roper in
there and somebody else contemplates it
and three different people come up with
three different uh reasons why he got a
rope run those are three different
movies you all saw and I like that idea
I like the idea that you opened up the
briefcase in Pulp Fiction and I don't
tell you what's in there yeah but it's
up to you to figure out what's in there
and now that's your movie and you'll
make that decision somewhere down the
line now if I tell you at this table
what it is then you'll throw that away
and I don't want you to throw away
that's your movie